don't forget my name's Pat do you ever
feel like being a goat meat oh let's
play oh Jesus sky it starts right away
doesn't it okay
I am a goat I know I can lick things
what the [ __ ] was that
okay I can become a ragdoll I get points
for becoming a rag doll ah Jesus Christ
man what's that five guys are odd why
Jesus Christ I can't
I'm sorry I'd catch it what the [ __ ]
what kind of drugs were they on when
they made this hey wake up come on let
me love you oh Jesus come on son of a
goat hey guys skull on here what are
they protesting against get out of the
way I'm in charge now [ __ ] that's
right
kneel before your Creator or break that
or that oh Jesus this is some call that
a [ __ ] [ __ ] man call of duty and go
[ __ ] itself hi guys sorry I just wanted
some potato chips [ __ ] love potato
chip line can we blow up these gas tea
Oh haha Michael Bay big chase Oh what is
this this is creepy oh it's a rally it's
a race that's a good all you need to do
is play that say I'm fine
best defense mechanism ever the [ __ ] are
you guys dating tonight let's see if we
can locate this seemed like a good idea
in my head
vengeance oh [ __ ] how do I kill it I'm
gonna have to kill you all right let's
set a trap for him that worked great I
have this one this is what you get for
[ __ ] whip outs
what the hell all right this time not
you [ __ ] I'm taking my car I'll swear
have you ever thought hey I wanted to
take my car out for a walk
oh Jesus Christ what is this my daily
routine nice oh god oh god it keeps
stretching
I gotta keep stretching let's see how
far we can go I'm gonna assume infinity
oh Jesus it scared me ah Jesus cry why
my cards with his explosive tug that's
what she said I can only imagine playing
this game on bath salts probably no much
not much difference to be honest what
the hell is happening
what why do 360 front-door Bakula it's
is a skating game I don't understand
this game has changed my life I'm
getting new perspective on things
goat man it all makes sense this game is
a work of art it's just so beautiful
front flap Oh let's time put him here
well I'll go on the other side this is
not gonna end well
oh the car the car the car the car the
car oh come on what what the [ __ ] is in
here why is it sir seriously there's I'm
constantly farting it all makes sense
god dammit this is probably the most
believable character in the entire
universe that goat so hot right now
there's a flying pig I wonder if we can
attach to it or some [ __ ] that'd be
awesome
can I climb back I goat goat what are
you [ __ ] goat doesn't even know how
to climb ladders there you go you know
there's a mattress there it just in case
you get tired of walking all the stairs
oh Jesus Christ there's a trampoline
he's gonna be amazing
hey man do you come rafted oh no my love
my love what has happened to your oh ah
there you are there you are you're in
safe hands now come back to me
we're going to get married son we're
going to get married come with me don't
fight it
don't fight our inevitable of hey hi hey
leave the humping for the wedding night
okay hello it looks like he's climbing
the stairs
alright let's go on top of that building
there in the chat lean low gravity Oh
facility oh we gotta go there too go low
Oh goddammit get it ah [ __ ] out
hey guys met my friend yard again it's
contagious isn't it oh you want to meet
my friend Joe again hi Jagan don't cheat
on me god dammit
alright here we go baby
[Music]
yeah that's right you again that's how
we do it in the NGO town the Little Miss
Mayton let's make out
let's make out I know you don't fight it
don't fight it you again catch back my
catch me I'm not gonna kiss your junk ok
ok well I guess I have to okay there's
definitely something in there yes how
what the [ __ ] is that
stop help ya I got ya get my love don't
let go don't fight me I'm a goat Oh what
the [ __ ]
No I'm coming for you [ __ ] ain't nobody
steal my man
especially if I'm a goat well it what
the [ __ ] with the point seriously
why you son of a [ __ ] you leave me for
this whatever the you go down you go
down I say oh Jesus
alright he went to space probably taking
care of yoga and you [ __ ] I made out
with your genitals
alright let's you know what I'm gonna
get that little [ __ ] now yeah I can
you stay down there Wow he's fine do you
even go try the goat Marx's pray he gets
ready to attack and he goes oh I don't
even know what's going on
I'm buggy jumping and hang gliding at
the same time as a goat
this game just fulfills dreams all in
one [ __ ] yet oh god what is that yeah
this is my stop
karma I want to find a good place to
line Oh what's down there oh I want to
line on those alright what happens here
come on
well get my time on baby yeah we have to
try out the testing facility over
gravity and [ __ ] what's in here great
room my favorite so far probably a car
how do we get inside
that's what goats say there we go all
right we're in [ __ ] the police what goes
inside hey is in my domain now [ __ ]
let's find out how gravity works
I know it [ __ ] name Illuminati
[ __ ] going on here
ragdoll skate yeah 360 been skating ever
yeah
Tony Hawk and got [ __ ] on this [ __ ] I
hope some sweet lady saw that cuz that
was pretty good
hey car oh here it is that was easy
where I'm flying look at me now mom they
told me I couldn't become anything no
look at me I'm a flying goat this is the
greatest day of my life so sexy so sexy
so sexy ow all the front flips all the
front flips on the front flips front
flip that's how I do it on the go down
girl
that's how with the one in the go town
we just be hating they don't know how
much gold I am I got a [ __ ] oh my god oh
my god I can't all right that's enough
for one episode brothers I'm definitely
playing more of this leave a like if you
enjoyed watching it helps me out a lot
it's this guy Tacoma Road today and I'll
see in the next one love you bro say
awesome
[Music]